hablamos ahora de nuestra salud aquí en
directo américa ya está comido en el
estudio más romeros a la mar bienvenida
a feliz miércoles para usted vamos a
hablar hoy del coi 19 está mente la
maternidad porque avanza la información
alrededor de las consecuencias de los
contagios de las vacunas sobre las
personas embarazadas y también con hijos
así es raúl de hecho reina una cierta
confusión desde hace semanas incluso
meses alrededor de los efectos que tiene
el cómic 19 y también las vacunas sobre
las mujeres y las personas embarazadas y
para despejar todas estas dudas estamos
con el doctor oscar franco director del
instituto de medicina social y
preventiva de la universidad de berna
muy buenos días doctor como cada
miércoles cuéntenos qué efectos tienen
las vacunas sobre las personas
embarazadas las mujeres embarazadas y es
seguro que se inmunicen
respecto a la pregunta de si es seguro
la respuesta es sencilla y contundente
es un sí es seguro y ahora mismo lo
mejor que pueden hacer las personas
embarazadas para proteger su salud y la
de sus hijos es vacunarse lo antes
posible cada vez tenemos más estudios
que demuestran que la vacunación ni está
relacionada con el aborto ni con la
pérdida del embarazo ni con el parto
prematuro ni con infertilidad y lo que
estamos viendo es que generalmente
producen efectos o leves o moderados
similares a las mujeres que no están
embarazadas así que con toda esta
evidencia que tenemos es importante
anteponerse a los temores porque sé que
es una decisión difícil y protegerse y
proteger a la vida del niño con la
vacunación doctor muy buenas tardes para
ustedes ahora yo saludo yo desde nuestro
estudio le pregunto porque si hay mucha
información sobre este tema sigue
habiendo tanta confusión acerca de la
seguridad de las vacunas para las
mujeres en estado de embarazo
y lo que vimos fue el principio pues no
teníamos vacunas y luego cuando salieron
los primeros datos de la efectividad de
las vacunas no incluyen en los primeros
estudios las mujeres embarazadas por
precaución esto generó un espacio de
tiempo en el cual tuvimos que esperar a
que la evidencia apareciera y mientras
tanto los países fueron tomando y
adoptando medidas diferentes algunos
permitían la vacunación otros no
permitían la vacunación de las mujeres
vacunadas esto dio un espacio para que
saliera desinformación a través de
cadenas de whatsapp o en más redes
sociales que alertaron a las mujeres
acerca de posibles efectos adversos o
teorías conspirativas que realmente no
existían y generaron ese temor pero
ahora con toda la evidencia que tenemos
es importante importante de ponerse la
confusión y buscar la vacunación porque
debemos que es segura y es efectiva
claro doctor entonces para ayudar
también a tomar decisiones informadas a
quienes nos están escuchando cómo afecta
el contagio de kobe 19 en las mujeres
embarazadas
si hemos visto que mujeres embarazadas
han tenido que ser hospitalizadas o han
perdido la vida entonces pueden tener un
kobe 19 que tienen mayor riesgo de
severidad hospitalización puede muerte
comparado con personas de la misma edad
pero que no están embarazadas no
solamente pueden afectar a las mujeres
sino que también pueden afectar a sus
hijos oa sus niñas ya que pueden generar
un parto prematuro antes de lo esperado
y esto puede llevar a consecuencias en
el desarrollo infantil tanto el corto
mediano y largo plazo por eso es tan
importante no solamente proteger la
salud de la persona embarazada sino
también de el niño o la niña que van a
hacer y no creer tampoco doctor y marc
en esos rumores para eso está espacios
como el de nosotros donde decimos pues
información ya verificada doctor y
también le quiero preguntar después del
parto cómo se sabe cómo se transmiten
estos anticuerpos de las madres a sus
bebés
si esta pregunta es investigado en
varios estudios ha mirado si hay
anticuerpos por ejemplo en la leche
materna en el cordón umbilical y se han
encontrado anticuerpos específicos
contra el coronavirus tanto en la leche
materna como en el cordón umbilical así
que tenemos ya una confirmación de la
presencia de estos anticuerpos y sabemos
en unos estudios recientes que evaluaron
en mujeres que habían tenido kobe 19 que
continúan produciendo anticuerpos en la
leche materna incluso diez meses después
entonces vemos que esos anticuerpos no
solamente pueden proteger al niño contra
el cob y 19a la niña contra el joven 19
sino que también tiene una duración que
es es larga es llegar a los 10 meses
hasta ahora en lo que se ha investigado
entonces estos anticuerpos que hablaba
de personas y madres contagiadas de
cobain 19 pasa lo mismo cuando los
anticuerpos son producidos por una
vacuna
también se ha estudiado con diferentes
vacunas ha estudiado con la vacuna de
moderna con la de fallecer con la de
janssen y lo que se ha visto es que el
hasta el 100 por ciento de las personas
vacunadas con modernas en la leche
materna tenían anticuerpos específicos
contra el coronavirus en las de facer se
acercaba al 90% y en la vacuna de
janssen llegaba a cerca del 71 por
ciento y esos anticuerpos son de
diferentes tipos ya sea tipo a tipo g
pero lo importante es que son
anticuerpos que contra que ayudan
combatir el coronavirus por lo tanto
nuevamente repetir lo que habíamos dicho
al principio que la mejor decisión que
se puede tomar en las personas
embarazadas para proteger su salud y la
de sus hijos o hijas es vacunarse doctor
muchas gracias por toda la información y
también por despejar todas nuestras
dudas como siempre